hello everyone welcome back to the lobby
gamespot's weekly hangout here at 2 p.m
pacific in sunny san francisco i'm mike
maherty your host
back for the first time in what two
weeks was it from uh years two years
from uh marty's been dead this whole
time from uh like what like a soul walk
in asia kind of across that continent i
walked on the soles of my feet that's
pete brown hi that was
doctor
yeah this is scott butterworth hello
uh we're gonna bring scott on we have a
lot to talk about today we are going to
talk about sieve the review titanfall 2
which i reviewed dark souls 3 dlc final
fantasy 15 the first 15 hours or however
long they played but first we want to
get into something kind of newsworthy um
bethesda gary steinman the global
content lead on bethesda's blog just
released something that's of interest to
us through especially who review games a
lot pete you're the reviews editor um
but as i was saying you know like early
in the year doom we got review copy what
a day early and people were speculating
maybe that means the game itself is
gonna like suck or whatever they were
saying on twitter and it turned out to
be a really good game and
that like kind of led to more
conversations around i know like 2k the
publisher our last few releases hasn't
really given us the games that early in
advance at all um so it's kind of as
reviewers doesn't give us as much time
but a lot of people keep thinking this
means that you know these games are not
going to be great because they're not
giving the reviewers like two weeks in
advance to play them right but um no but
that's just saying that's just how it
works now um do you want to talk about
that a little bit like did you read
through the blog post i have it up now i
can kind of quote it if you want but
yeah i mean throw a quick quote out
there like i think just to sort of give
their their aim um
um so yeah so on the blog it says with
the upcoming launches of skyrim special
edition and dishonored 2 both of which
bethesda will be publishing we will
continue our policy of sending media
review copies one day before release
while we will continue to work with the
media streamers and youtubers support
their coverage both before and after
release we want everyone including those
in the media to experience our games at
the same time right okay so yes people
might assume these these games are bad
but when a company says all our games
are going to be handled this way that
immediately doesn't really make sense
that kind of conclusion i mean the best
conclusion you could really make here is
that
i don't think these companies are scared
of bad reviews but i think that they are
willing to
take sort of more of the control over
the messaging around something be it
good or bad
and yeah it can suck for a lot of
reasons for us as reviewers given that
it's our job and it definitely can suck
for a lot of consumers who rely on
reviews to buy games like there's no
question this doesn't do anything for
the consumer this is a thing that really
just benefits bethesda um so you may see
it change some of the ways that you know
games are reviewed because obviously we
can't review a 20-hour game after one
day
so there'll be maybe some different
types of coverage around that i mean
we've got to figure that out and
bethesda might follow suit or other
companies might follow in bethesda's
footsteps so who knows but i think
it's interesting to say the least
and will certainly make uh our jobs
very different
yeah because i was going to say like
looking back at recent examples scott
you reviewed
both of these games yeah mafia earlier
this month in sieve just this past
weekend both of which were published by
2k and so that's kind of like there's a
shocking disparity between them because
you know mafia 3 for as many good things
as it did we talked about it a lot but
it got you gave it a six and i think
like
overall just like regardless of the
scores it was very much like it was kind
of on the lower end especially like
technical value so that's kind of like
one of the games that people would
assume would be released or like given
us code like the day before but then six
comes out and you loved it we're gonna
talk about it uh briefly uh the score
itself briefly in a little bit but like
across the board people are really
liking it they say it's one of the
better entries in the series and whatnot
so there's kind of a huge juxtaposition
between those and you kind of saw the
in terms of time management you saw like
the
both of those as as pete pointed out we
can't review certain games you know in
given one day lead time like civ is way
too big and mafia it turned out was like
a 40-hour game as well so trying to
review that in a day is
quite literally impossible there just
aren't enough hours in the day as the
saying goes um but also as you just
pointed out the disparity between the
qualities of civ and mafia sort of calls
into question that prevailing narrative
that oh getting a game late means it's
going to be bad because in mafia's case
yeah there were definitely some
technical problems on every platform so
that kind of validated that that theory
right that oh you've got if you get a
ladybird's gonna be bad but sieve i mean
aside from a few problems maybe with the
ai which i experienced less than other
people actually um but aside from that
there were no real problems the game is
great uh there's there was no real
reason for them to hold back in terms of
you know concerns about quality like
they they had to have known that it was
a really good game and it is yeah so
yeah i i'm actually with pete that i i
think that
i don't know to me this decision by
bethesda doesn't necessarily serve
consumers but at the same time i think
it just reflects natural shifts in the
landscape i mean youtubers and then that
type of thing that's it's a thing now
right like the media is not the only
option for for games coverage so us not
getting the games as early as we used to
in my mind it's just a reflection of the
times and the way things work and i
don't know it was always a privilege to
get games ahead of time they're a
commercial product and it was we were
very fortunate uh to to get stuff early
but i don't think we were ever entitled
to that so you know yeah yeah and look
at kind of just interesting yeah quick
if you look at final fantasy 15 right
like
we got 50 access to like over a dozen
hours of that game like a month ahead of
launch that's pretty beefy for a preview
so maybe this will just change the way
that previews are handled yeah which
could be a good thing sure and then
looking back at 2k with both and this is
both for access game as well with civ 6
and xcom 2. we both essentially had for
both those uh i reviewed xm2 scotty did
civ6 we essentially had access to almost
the whole game minus like i forget like
a few features next time too and of
course you can't review it based on
those builds alone because they don't
have everything that could kind of
change the formula they also you know
like civ didn't have all the leaders
possible but
still like you said maybe that's
changing how coverage is done people
will probably see more reviews and
progress a little more often well
obviously with bethesda games and um
with 2k games you know like ea recently
we've done a couple ea reviews recently
uh titanfall 2 i just did and i did the
event and that was well in advance of
the review embargo yesterday
activision had a call of duty event
recently and our review hasn't even gone
up yet so we have time with certain
publishers and i don't know it's just
kind of
like you said an indicator of how things
are changing yeah it does its own weird
thing though with ea early access like
that's
for battlefield and i mean you know it
goes up the week ahead of its stated
launch but only for people who subscribe
to ea access but of course we can do
that and so it's weird every publisher
does it in different ways but clearly
it's changing for everybody and then
like not to mention betas and alphas and
stress tests and close alphas and close
betas and whatnot but yeah you mentioned
them i know uh anyway okay cool so let's
get right into the game we're just
talking about civilization six scott
your full review is up we did like an
ask the reviewer type thing about a week
ago when you first got it um you
seemed pretty positive on it you said it
had some annoyances but your review is
now up i want to talk briefly about the
score before we get into like the
segment itself which is like where does
this fall in the grand scheme of the
civilization series which is 25 years
old as of like last month or something
but
what what led you to give to nine score
why do you like this game so much
that's that's a big question i spent a
lot of words answering that question
it's it's tough and actually
it was a bit tricky to score i
definitely considered giving it at eight
certain points simply because there are
some frustrations with it i mean there's
some things about the ui that still
really annoy me and the the ai the ai
opponent and single player are
definitely not perfect i didn't have
nearly as much trouble with them as
certain people in our comments who were
like it's broken it's the game is i
can't even play it which was not my
experience even if occasionally the ai
would do stupid things but setting that
aside i i
even those issues never stopped me from
wanting to continue playing it is just
such an engrossing experience and
discovering all of the nuances that have
been added since 5 and learning uh all
about the big changes which we've
discussed at length previously uh
including like uns unstacking the cities
and active research and agendas for uh
for
for leaders i mean all these big changes
make it really fascinating to me as a
longtime civ fan for someone who's not
super familiar with the franchise
because like everything you just said
makes sense to me because i love the
franchise and people that really want to
play this and have been waiting for it
for months or like because they didn't
even announce it until about
may or june they kind of said hey this
is the next numbered entry it's not
beyond earth it's not an expansion this
is the next numbered entry it's coming
out in four months that's not always the
case but for someone who doesn't really
understand the franchise and like was
considering getting into it is civ six a
good entry point
i would i would say it is actually yeah
um
i don't think that any of the games are
any better or worse a place to jump in
because no matter where you start civ is
a bit
demanding um i was actually talking to
jake decker one of our video producers
who was just playing civ for the first
time she started with civ6 and and i
think that starting in the series there
is a pretty daunting learning curve um
because there are a lot of systems at
play and there's a lot to just remember
and manage in any given play through
that said though i think that civ 6 does
an elegant job of inserting its new
ideas in in a in a way that makes sense
that slots naturally into the structure
and and the overall structure of the
game is very understandable i mean
you're establishing a civilization right
and you're taking it very slowly step by
step from a single settler and a single
warrior up through the space age right
so if every match evolves very gradually
and so if you take your time and you're
willing to put in the hours and into a
full playthrough by the end of that
first playthrough i feel like anybody
will have a firm grasp of what the game
is like and what it entails and that
remains true for civ six and there is a
full uh tutorial for civ six as well
that's like fully voiced and pretty
brisk and i think it really will help
new players so in my mind this is this
is a great place to start if you've
never played a sift game yeah and that's
the thing that's tough with these kind
of games and we did a recent uh video
shoot at faraxis in maryland and a lot
of them expressed the same sentiment
that it's a series that they almost
nailed the formula back with like i mean
even like civ 3 the last game with this
like sprites before i went to like 3d
with c4 like that far back it's almost
like they nailed that board game
simulation kind of
turn base you know one more turn formula
so with each entry it's all like what
features are they going to change
obviously unstacking the cities whereas
they used to be on one tile now you're
like spreading them across multiple
districts on different hex tiles but
uh you know like active research becomes
this side quest kind of thing almost
with the science that can boost and like
maybe turn you a different direction or
like boost like the path you're going
down but
it's almost like where does civ six fall
in the pantheon of sieve games in terms
like the improvements they've made
because sip five release and it was
imperfect well as most things are but
five release was really good but there
are a lot of things wrong with it but
then you know gods and kings and brave
new world came out the expansion it's
like this is the game c5 should have
been like can you see them making
certain changes to six that'll like kind
of maybe make it like
not like objectively but a really good
game in the series uh well so this this
is a pretty big question and a difficult
question to answer especially you know
within the first week of the game's
release because as you pointed out civ
games have a habit of growing pretty
substantially after release so
inevitably i think there will be a lot
of big changes and big additions to six
that we haven't yet seen and honestly
there's still plenty of stuff about the
base game that i'm still coming to grips
with and learning about and you know
figuring out how it all kind of connects
together but i will say that the base
game i i think as i said in the review i
think civ 6 is the strongest based game
civilization's ever released it is
certainly stronger than civ 5 was when
it first came out so if i was actually
pretty bare bones in a lot of ways when
it first released and and the the dlc
that came later fleshed it out into this
really rich and deep experience so
arguably the best civ experience you can
have is civ 5 plus all of the
expanded content i think civ 6 actually
kind of matches that experience in a lot
of ways but it'll kind of boil down to
preference i mean i think with every new
civilization there's a certain set of
players who remain behind and continue
to play the experience they know and
experience they love and honestly that's
fine it's kind of a matter of taste
because six really does change a lot of
things and not everybody's gonna love
those things so saying it's best is like
such a hopelessly subjective thing and
and you know so i i think that six is
great i think it's the strongest base
game for sure i think there's stuff that
they could add to make it even stronger
um but i think that veterans will find
stuff that makes it feel new and fresh
and is genuinely exciting and like i
said before i think it's a good entry
point for new players as well sure and
it's actually it was like fascinating to
look at because the team that made the
expansions for five is the team that
made six so it's like ed beats lead
designer these are the people that like
kind of almost you know like really
iterated on five to the point of like
like you said with brave new world and
gods and kings this is kind of that's
that itself as exists now might be one
of the better you know objective entries
in the series and you can see a lot of
those ideas in six already you can see
that that six it doesn't really follow
five it follows the expansions right it
feels like the next logical progression
from from that point not from the last
base game like the espionage is intact
from the expansions right that kind of
system yeah and social policies as well
have been kind of like revamped but are
similar to how they were in the
expansions yeah and those i mean those
ideas came a bit later um so a lot of
stuff like that has been you know uh
expanded upon and included in the base
game that was not present at all in the
base version of civilization five so how
many hours have you put in by now ooh
about 60 something like that since last
like thursday what four or five yeah
matches
uh about four okay so i i won with every
possible win condition which is uh
uh well actually you know one of my
first game was technically a score
victory uh so it's culture science
religion and domination four ways you
can win um so i pursued all of those the
first time i actually didn't
successfully complete a science thing i
was very near the end but ran out of
time i just went through score yeah but
i had been pursuing science in that
first playthrough a few months ago when
we had the preview build and i think uh
one of us like i saw it at a judge's
week like back during the summer i've
played a fair amount of this game even
though i haven't played that much like
post release but you and i had a
conversation about how it kind of avoids
that boring mid game uh like how does
the flow of each match i cannot talk to
you during the ask your reviewer but i
want to touch on it for people who might
not have seen it because like now it's
fully up the review like nine out of ten
you really love this game but how does
the actual flow of each match go from
like the beginning to end because the
beginning 150 turns are always the ones
where you're like to me they're the most
fun and most people are the most fun
that's when you're planning things out
fighting barbarians kind of discovering
other civilizations natural wonders the
villages that give you gifts and whatnot
how does like each play through kind of
progress do you ever get bored in a
specific spot each time
not in the same spot each time there are
certain things like with science that
kind of it drags out a little bit at the
end because you're just waiting like ah
build you know finish researching this
particular space thing that i need to
win the game you're just like waiting
for the turns to pass right um but i
think that in previous civilization
games there was always kind of a point
where you could mentally check out a bit
at least for a little while in the
middle as you waited for your big
picture decisions to pan out i think i
used that exact phrase in the review
actually uh but this time around i think
unstacked cities which you mentioned
earlier help keep you engaged throughout
um the biggest one of the biggest
changes at least that the unstacked city
spring is there's no longer a global
happiness and food level instead it's
managed on a local basis which means you
have to pay a lot more attention to
individual cities which is both um
not tedious but definitely demanding but
it also creates a lot of opportunities
for strategic gain so even though you
are investing time in this new way it
actually can pay off and and it does
keep you invested it does keep you
immersed in the experience more deeply
because each turn matters there's
something that you have to accomplish on
any given turn that can contribute to
your overall goals it's no longer just
okay i gotta wait for this technology to
finish researching so i can then move
forward there's always something in the
immediate turn you can be doing to
improve your chances
there's always this weird disconnect to
talk like bigger picture for a second
civilization's been around for 25 years
since 1991 and despite the fact that
like not like if we went to the gamespot
office right now and said like how many
people want to play six i'm sure a lot
of people want to try it out but like i
think like in terms of die hard people
that have been sticking with it there's
me there's you there's probably a few
others but it still seems sort of niche
even though it's one of the biggest
names in like turn-based strategy in a
lot of ways they have shaped the forex
strategy genre and influenced like even
real-time strategy in some respects i
don't know like pete have you ever been
interested in or played this series that
much i've played a few forex games
before that i've really enjoyed i played
like early sieve uh endless space a few
years ago i thought was pretty awesome
and i really want to play sip six as
much as i really wanted to play civ 5
because my hobby is my job so much of my
time is spent playing games i just don't
have that much time to play something
like civ 6 to really like sit down and
dedicate all those extra hours which is
unfortunate but i definitely want to
play it like but i can imagine how for a
lot of people
civ might feel too intimidating in terms
of like i can't wrap my head around this
immediately like i know what a first
person shooter is i know what a
platformer is i can imagine that civ is
this complicated simulation game but do
i really know what that means do i
really want to take you know i want to
take the effort to figure that out but i
can imagine for a lot of people that
might seem like almost a chore in and of
itself yeah to get started yeah i mean
like in recent months and years we've
kind of stopped looking at addicting
games as a good thing like i think in
old reviews if you read them and say
this game's addicting as hell it's like
9 out of 10 like this you need to play
this but
civ like despite how boring it can sound
the fact that you're macro and
micromanaging this civilization from the
beginning of time to the future
it really is that's like their mantra is
one more turn and like it's hard to like
really get bored when there's always
something to worry about like a new
research to complete a new building to
finish like in this case a new district
to build like your city's gonna be
unfolding you could build the sphinx you
could build the pyramids and whatnot
it's always kind of
been really fun to me for whatever
reason but it's always hard you explain
it well in your review why it is fun and
engaging but again like this series is
so intimidating it's crazy it's been
around for 25 years like not many series
have it's like no no like there's mario
there's zelda stuff like that um but i
don't know like civ 6 like in your
opinion you said this kind of matches up
with the version of civ 5 as it is now
i i mean i would say so yeah it is
ultimately like i said
completely subjective because there are
enough big changes to six that not
everyone who loves five in the
expansions is necessarily gonna love six
but in terms of like feature richness
and the way in which it all slots
together and sort of the logic driving
all of the interlocking systems of the
game yeah it's like an incredibly robust
experience there's so much to sink your
teeth into a phrase that i really hate
i don't know why they came out of my
mouth but there's just so much for for
your brain to absorb and to think about
and just there's so many wheels turning
at any given time that yeah i think
people who are willing to put in the
time which the game does demand are
going to be completely engrossed and and
to me that the level of investment does
of six does rival what i experienced
with five in the expansions so to be
completely subjective for you is this
the best civ game you've ever played
this is certainly my favorite civ game i
guess um and i i've spent i mean i i
opened the review talking about like
playing the original civilization with
my dad it came out when i was five years
old but i remember being like oh
catapults are awesome yeah i didn't
really understand the game but yeah i
understood enough that i kept playing it
it's weird i'm like more nostalgic about
civ than i'm about mario sure which is
weird for someone my age but completely
true for whatever reason definitely yeah
so that's sieve six it is released uh as
of friday the 21st uh we give it a nine
night scott you give it a nine out of
ten our full review is up on gamespot
along with a video review if you wanna
check that out uh go read that go watch
it let us know you think in the comments
below
scott i'm gonna have to boot you off
thanks so much for coming on and talking
siv yet again appreciate it bye
hi what's up dude
it's been so long i forgot what you
looked like almost lots of hair i've
been cat sitting your cat you weren't
you stayed at my place the cutest punk
i've ever met in my life he is he's
quite a handful he's a cute guy he's
talking about that again i'm talking
about my cat yeah his cat kenji uh yeah
this is matt spinelli hi how's it going
matt what have you been up to much just
working on final fantasy 15 related
content well coincidentally we're gonna
talk about that yeah that's true final
fantasy xv
you and a few other people got the
chance to play it the preview build
which was pretty massive from my
understanding but you specifically
played 15 hours like the first five
chapters like uh walk us through what
you got the chance to check out uh yeah
so it was the first five chapters
which technically is about like
give or take around 12-ish hours but
like i spent a few hours doing a lot of
like side content
uh so yeah it just starts you off in the
beginning of the game and uh throws you
off right into the open world basically
yeah yeah so i don't really know the
series all that well i mean i know it
like in passing enough to like
understand why it's important and why
people love it but correct me if i'm
wrong this is the first like truly open
world final fantasy is that incorrect or
is that misleading
uh it depends on how you look at it yeah
okay like i mean you probably from what
i understand you can't just go anywhere
from the start yeah that's true but it's
big like in the way that the mmos are
big right like if you're strong enough
if you have the abilities you can get
there okay yeah but you did say like
pretty soon after you started you were
in like just an open world right yeah
that's what's different uh i want to say
compared to a lot of the other previous
final fantasies that have had similar
sort of qualities to it um you're
literally thrown into the open world uh
within the first 10 minutes which you
know was bonfire 13. that took
well over like 20 or so hours or so i
mean like 30 40. i don't even know
but
that's that's a long intro
but uh but yeah um
i think that's sort of the most distinct
quality of it um
did it feel like there's a lot to do or
was it kind of you i remember you i read
your preview we were editing and you
said there's a lot of fetch quests did
was there a lot of uh substance to the
quest you're doing or was just kind of
running around fetching things for
people getting tasks done
yeah see that's the thing like you do
there are a lot of side quests that
emerge besides sort of the main stuff
that you get to do
um
most of those they do follow a very
standard fetch quest format sometimes a
little too much where it's like hey go
to point a get this thing go to point b
give it to that person and then go back
to point uh point eight in order to
complete the quest and
some of the some quests don't really add
that much in terms to the overall sort
of context of the conflict that takes
place in the game uh so it can be a
little
um
like it doesn't really feel like um
there's not a ton of substance yeah a
ton of substance sure so to say yeah can
you walk me through the world itself
it's such a weird i mean i know final
fantasy always kind of does this but
there's a it's like this weird
amalgamation of like magic and weird
like i see in reality highway 69 diners
and cars and
boys and leather i don't know 69 diners
and boys and leather what is highway 16
66.
is that the one yeah
it's the route 60. there you go mine's
in the gutter uh jesus i love the 69
diner as much as the xbox so
how's this world feel to you matt to
avoid pete's conversation
um
as you said there's a lot of
i guess the way to describe it it's very
uh inspired by sort of americana kind of
like you know having a lot of sort of
these
pit stop areas you're on basically the
aesthetic of the game is very much a
road trip um
so that's kind of what leads you
through uh lead you through the story um
sorry
yeah the world itself is like i mean
it's a weird kind of like you said it's
like this road trip thing i always got
like i remember the first trailer was
kind of like that uh stand by me covered
by that girl i don't i didn't get the
aesthetic they're going for at all i've
been trying to pay attention to final
fantasy 15 but it seems like they're
going for so many different things did
the world feel like connected to you did
it feel engaging do you want to go back
and see more of this world now you
played like 15 hours of it very much so
um
that's that's the thing like i really
there's a lot to do there really is it's
a very big game and a lot of the stuff
that you get to do really emerges
organically for the most part despite
some of the fetch quest nature of the
site activities you get to do but
there's just so many different places to
explore a lot of
activities to do besides you know even
just fetch quests of course you could
just like
hop on a chocobo and explore you know
and that's what i really like about the
game um it has a very distinct quality
compared to other final fantasies
yeah like what's this like for me a good
final fantasy game has a certain spark
to it that like
when you play it you're like yeah this
is final fantasy like no other series
kind of attaches such importance to like
a weird quirk like
what is the quirk that makes this
feel like legitimately final fantasy
like it can't be the chocobos it can't
be the summons like what is it about
this rpg in particular that feels like
it fits in the series if anything at
this stage
this dinosaur ostrich he's writing
that's a chocobo you don't
i'm just trolling both of you no i
really didn't know that was chocobo
i'm not the best one to talk about final
fantasy see that's a good question i
mean
i think what makes this game
distinctly final fantasy i think final
fantasy as a series has always been
it's always challenged itself to change
uh and
to redefine itself uh and what it is
either that be like because you know
when font fancy first some of the
earlier games was very more traditional
fantasy setting but then you have seven
which kind of delves a little bit more
into the sort of steampunk aesthetic
changing what we can expect out of final
fantasy as a series i think
that's what 15 does again that's what i
like about it um it's contemporary like
very contemporary it feels like
everything is just kind of modern day
with you know a dash of magic on it
totally totally
it it definitely asked that question of
like
you know what what can a final fantasy
game be well
for 15 like yeah a final fantasy game
can be sort of this long extended road
trip that takes place some sort of a
huge open world it can be
a a game that does tie itself closer to
reality and i think that's what 15 i
think it captures with a final fantasy
in general this desire to kind of change
things up redefine itself throughout the
years cool to get into a couple
specifics quick uh we're watching combat
right now how did that feel when you're
playing because you said in your preview
you played you had like an extensive
time with that as well
uh combat feels great i really like it a
lot it's okay so it's more action
focused it's not very much it's not like
sort of a turn-based
um battle system that we've seen in sort
of previous games it's real time yeah
yeah definitely but you can play by
pausing it you can't you can actually
i've tried out that mode a little bit um
because what it does is like in the
middle of action if you don't move it'll
just pause the action and you have a
little time bar that moves that just
basically gives you like a limited time
to think it's almost like that to do
next a little fallout very similar
actually yeah okay um
but yeah the the comment system in
general is it reminds me a lot of like
an action game like sort of a more
hardcore action game like devil may cry
bayonetta nowhere near as sort of
complex as those systems as demanding
but uh it definitely gives you a lot of
room to
be stylish in your combat because you
have a lot of different weapons you can
equip different types of weapons that
have their own distinct attacks that you
can literally switch to on the fly as
you're beating up a dude okay so but
like overall in general after 15 hours
of this you sound pretty positive on it
you sound like you want to play it again
when it releases what in november
november 30th november 30th final
fantasy 15 finally got delayed a couple
times yeah but you sound positive
this game has been delayed for like
eight years yeah yeah yeah just a little
well i've spent ten years in the making
now yeah yeah whatever yeah overall like
despite some of the issues i might have
had with sort of the fetch quest nature
of it all uh and even some bits with the
story uh which haven't really dabbled
upon too much yet but um i am very
excited to return to the world i really
want to see because i really want to see
what this game has to offer because it's
very promising there's a lot of
different things that make it so
distinct of itself
uh redefining some of the things that
i've come to expect from final fantasy
over the years that you know i just
really want to dive in and see what
happens cool awesome a lot i mean i
don't really play the series but it
looks like something i might want to try
out if i have time but pete you're
probably super excited for this i'm
pretty excited yeah i'm super
apprehensive but i'm but i'm excited
yeah right well the game actually opens
with it's it's interesting how the game
it opens with the message saying like a
final fantasy for fans and first timers
so
could be part of that first timer a lot
man okay interesting uh you know like
ideally each sequel would be for first
timers as well but that's true maybe
they worked around this time cool that
is final fantasy 15. you can read our
full preview it's up on site we have
some video content as well uh both from
matt spinelli and that releases november
30th so tell us what you think are you
excited for it leave your thoughts in
the comments below
madaspinali thanks so much for coming on
man of course i appreciate it go play
more final fantasy or something i will
what about the comments above no one
ever gives any attention to the comments
about the comments above that would just
throw off the whole flow you well i mean
i guess it's
like what a lot of people do they go
comment before they read everything this
would just facilitate that process you
should not have taken me seriously no i
know you're trying to play off it yeah
oh whoa
eric hey what's up what up what have you
been up to
uh
dark souls and destiny you sound tired
yeah i stayed up late playing dark souls
because like i didn't have i gave up my
early
like review copy to someone on the video
team so that they can make content
so i basically
waited till nine p i for some reason
playstation got it last so last week
xbox one somehow it leaked dark souls
was like available for whatever reason
on friday mistakes
uh and then sometimes you just use three
fingers for a quotation mark oh
yeah and then he's not human it's not
gonna play with people listening but
i'm sorry yeah sorry
but then i started noticing people were
playing on pc before like 9 00
p.m pacific which would be 12 a.m
eastern yesterday i was like man i'm
on the last one i'm just like sitting
here waiting until nine o'clock and so i
just played to like one or two cool cool
yeah well anyway yeah we are here to
talk about the dark souls 3 the newest
dlc uh it releases
when is that actually it is out came out
last night okay nine so okay so you but
it did leak last week yeah on xbox one
you said okay cool so i guess like the
main thing i want to know is what is
going on in this dlc is it worth
returning to dark souls 3-4 in this like
slew of holiday releases sure uh lore
wise i can't help you too much because i
didn't play too much of the soul stuff
before but um you're pretty much going
into uh
ariandel if i'm saying that right i
guess yeah something similar yeah so
it's like a snowy place um
it's worth it in the sense that you know
anyone that plays dark souls probably
wants to play more dark souls right so
like for me like not having not played
dark souls for so long since you know
like release
uh it's that whole like learning how to
play again and then like being
frustrated at first because
uh it does kind of what that old old
hunters did where the first couple areas
you're just getting swarmed by people
instead of like running into like one or
two people it's just like they're all
over the place and you're just like
frantically like dodging or rolling
around
and then getting frustrated from dying
because like you kind of forgot how to
play and you don't have the muscle
memory but then
ultimately
being rewarded once you figure it out
again like oh yeah this is why i like
dark souls because it's like really
fluid and you feel like satisfied and
rewarded when you actually like okay i
learned how he's going to attack me i
can dodge like eight wolves now and kill
them all and it's fine um but yeah i
mean it's basically if you play it
you're going to want to play it i guess
if you play dark souls you're probably
going to play dark souls 3 dlc right for
people who have played all dark souls 3
it might be on like a second or third
consecutive playthrough is it easy to
get to the ashes of arendelle dlc like
how do because remember like hunters
right what's like the level
recommendation uh so from what i know
it's that if you're like say you have a
new game then you're just like in your
um normal just first playthrough
assuming you haven't beat it for some
reason uh
it's about 70 to 80 is about the level
you want to be at for the uh content the
dlc content and it's actually really
easy to get to you just go to the uh
cathedral of the the you know of the
deep
i think i could probably just like i
probably just screwed that up but like
you know what
are you anywhere you fight the fort or
the no dancer the boreal valley neither
it's uh where you fight the gang mob of
priests oh right the bottom floor yeah
so it is okay
right okay so
um you take that uh bonfire and then the
moment you get to that bonfire there's
just like a dude
that's kind of like
to the side that's kind of praying and
just talking to himself you let him
go through his little monologue then you
talk to him he's like touch this
painting a piece of a painting and he's
like touch it come on and then like all
of a sudden no you don't it's still
predatory that's not a painting
yeah seriously so then you know of
course you're dumb and you touch it and
then it just like vacuums you into that
world it's like the matrix or alice in
wonderland or the witcher 3 dlc do the
same thing yeah i don't know maybe
that's like an easy way to get people
into dlc now is to suck them into
paintings or mirrors i mean they did
that in bloodborne too right like the
alien just like
black holed you into a new area true
yeah so i guess at a certain point you
don't care as much how to get there as
like actually getting there yeah but how
long did it take you to finish uh so i
haven't beat it i'm on what i think is
the last boss i'm pretty sure like i'm
almost positive
uh it took me about five hours i think
to get to last boss um granted
again playing like really late at night
and starting to get frustrated i was
trying to like rush through parts and
like that just ate up like 30 to 40
minutes of just being really stupid of
you know you can't rush through some of
that stuff yeah knowing dark souls this
could the last boss could take you
anywhere from half an hour to yeah two
hours exactly so
i would say the dlc is probably like a
six to eight anywhere from like five to
eight probably actually rather uh
depending on how good you are how like
leveled you are maybe you're over
leveled you know um or you're just
really good at the game so it just
depends which is which is fair i think
it's 15 for just this dlc or you buy the
season pass which would be both dlcs for
24.99 okay
watching the gameplay right now it looks
really open i mean i remember old
hunters was a little more open than
bloodborne was because bloodborne had
the branching paths as like you know the
from software games tend to do uh dark
souls 3 the base game as well was kind
of there's some open areas like when you
get to the woods at the beginning um but
it was still also like specific paths to
take is that kind of the case here um
the cool thing about this area is most
of it kind of interweaves with each
other which is what dark souls 3 did a
good job of as well so it's kind of like
you go this way and you're like oh i
kind of loop back around and in terms of
the areas they are
for the most part more like open areas
like you see this area there's what
happens i don't want to spoil too much
wait it's early so it's fine um you know
you're this is kind of like near the
start and you happen to see wolves and
some of them howl and then guess what
the whole family comes and you're kind
of surrounded and the the wolves the ai
actually is like relatively smart in the
sense that as you're running away they
try to circle and they try to cut you
off so that you know
that kind of pack mentality i guess so
that they kind of like
surround you um
but it's intense uh there's a couple
areas like this that are like really
open and there's just like three four or
five enemies like surrounding you so you
have to kind of like deal with that
properly but of course in true dark
souls fashion there are also very tight
linear paths on like mountains where
there's two guys in front of you and
guess what you kind of gotta like
pull one away hopefully and then kill
him and then kill the next guy and hope
that you don't
roll off the ledge i rolled off the
ledge or a mountain at least two or
three times not but only because you
were tired and it was late at night no i
there's a couple where i just straight
up botched because
it's it's like that old hunters thing i
i hate to keep kind of comparing it but
they for those who aren't like
completely familiar with the bloodborne
dlc yes so
for some reason some of the the enemy
types in this uh like you think that
they're gonna be like
running out of stamina after like three
sets of moves and he just does like a
fourth that doesn't really make sense
like oh yeah i can finally attack you
because you straight up did like a
jumping smash melee within follow-up two
melees he's got to be available no turns
out he just doesn't care and he can keep
attacking um so you got to kind of get
used to that too but there aren't in my
opinion there aren't that many enemy
types and
so like once you figure them out there's
like a handful and once you figure them
out it's not so bad it's more about
managing fighting like multiple like
different
enemies i guess of the of the few that
there are a lot of wolves from what i'm
seeing right now yeah there's a like
so if it's not just wolves then it's
like a viking guy with a wolf and then
you gotta deal with both of them
um
but yeah i kinda i really wish they kind
of just went down the path where they
combined both of them and made one midi
expansion instead of separating the dlcs
this is the first of two yeah this is
the first of two and i don't know
that's just a preference i guess i'd
rather have more at one time and wait
longer than like place on and be like
okay now i got to wait another like
three months until like the next one
comes out but they did that with dark
souls 2 so
so i really like the old hunters because
the bosses were pretty tough uh i had a
really hard time with some of them and
it actually kind of felt like it was
bloodborne still but it felt like they
did enough new things and like the world
itself more open and weird uh to like
kind of you know justify me buying that
expansion is this is that the case with
this or are you kind of more lukewarm on
this or overall what are your
impressions
the the of the
boss fights i'm not gonna say how many
of the boss fights i've done
they seem interesting enough i feel like
they're not
reinventing the wheel though they're not
so different you know then
stuff you've encountered over your dark
souls career or history of playing these
games but
there's enough of a like twist that's
like oh okay like this is kind of
stressful and
i know that i haven't even gotten to
whatever phase that i need to in the
last boss i'm fighting and i know
there's some surprises there so i
haven't seen all that but in terms of
just the stuff i played
it's worth 15 i mean if you're getting
five to six i mean
it's all relative right like how much
what's worth it to you kind of as a
consumer but i think if you're getting
five to six hours of a game that you
already enjoy playing and that's not
even me playing the pvp which they have
like 3v3 pvp and stuff like that now um
i think it's worth it i think anyone
that but like i said anyone that plays
dark souls is probably buying the dlc
right so sure yeah i'm excited to play
it i'm hoping to find time between all
like all these releases coming up uh we
have a bunch still left before the
holidays hit and then we have a bunch
more in the spring but yeah five six
hours seems like an ideal kind of time i
don't know like you said 15 seems like
agreeable but um that is ashes of
ariandel dlc for dark souls 3. it's 15
but you can buy it as a package for 25
with the next unannounced dlc and that
is out now on ps4 xbox one and pc
all right
yes gonna have to eject you well where's
our uh where's my substitute player yeah
this is justin haywald chronically late
last two weeks in a row today i
specifically told him i was like hey be
ready for your segment
he always comes on high energy though so
it's hard to be mad eric thank you see
you later
justin hayward i couldn't get in the
room it was locked we should uh talk to
security about that we should talk
security about making your badge not
working we should talk about security
about why you're allowed in here every
day for work why why did anyone let me
in the first place i have no idea uh
pete you're out i'm sure you saw all the
news in the coverage but we came in
early one morning to do red dead
redemption 2 live stream and also the
nintendo nx announcement which turned
out it's now a nintendo switch seems
super interesting i want to get your
take quick before we get into like what
the topic of this is like what kind of
games we want on it but
you uh you're pretty knowledgeable with
the tech of consoles and pcs in general
don't don't be modest uh you know you
know a lot of the stuff what's your take
on the switch are you excited for it uh
i am uh i don't care that it's not gonna
be super powered um
i care that it's gonna be good enough to
deliver the kind of games
that we're used to from nintendo and
then whatever else we get from third
parties i hope which is good enough for
their vision to live even if it doesn't
have all the you know visual flourishes
that we get on other consoles or you
know high resolution that's all fine i i
just i love what nintendo does because
it's always so different i didn't feel
like i got that with the wii u and this
feels like a genuine shift like we've
seen attachable controllers for tablets
that suck we've seen other manufacturers
try to do similar things but nintendo is
really good for the most part at
delivering interesting tech at the right
price with good build quality um again i
think the wii u is a bit of a misstep in
that regard but just looking at what
they're doing i think they're on the
right path um and i'm pleased to know
that they're working with nvidia because
their shield tablet which has been out
for a couple years now and seen a few
iterations has been pretty strong the
tech that they've used in that they're
sort of evolving with some more modern
touches to build a semi-custom chip
that should be really strong like i've
played metal gear rising on a tablet so
hey if i can play middle gear rising on
you know the nx and it's a cheap game
like that's cool so maybe i'll have
access to a lot of old games that are
really great for a cheap price get a lot
of great nintendo stuff as well
and truly be able to play like the wii u
made me think i could you know remotely
or locally at the same time um so i'm
excited for all of that like
who freaking knows what the games are
gonna be it's it's more i think that
they have a big reveal coming and then
that's this is just gonna be one form
factor there's also gonna be a smaller
form factor it's gonna have a built-in
camera it's gonna have a built-in
microphone and it's also going to be a
phone
that's a joke i'm just being dumb no no
but i mean
they have talked about maybe replacing
their handheld you know down the line um
oh my god
um
yeah i mean i'm always optimistic with
nintendo stuff and this time i don't
think it's it's unfounded because i've
got consoles that are powerful that are
traditional
and i don't necessarily like playing
games on my phone but i love my 3ds so
this can give me the best of my 3ds and
console
one more thing about the tech how will
the cartridges affect that as opposed to
like the disk of a wii u not much faster
loading times okay yeah i mean storage
more expensive harder to replace though
like yeah but like less prone to damage
if a game runs out of stock uh and then
you have to press you have to flash a
whole bunch more cartridges versus like
oh we ran out of stock let's print a
whole lot more whole bunch more disks
like i think that could be problematic
if only there was a way you could
download games
from the internet that that's is storage
gonna be like wait can the switch do
that
storage is gonna be a question like how
much on-board storage is there gonna be
is it i feel like they've got their own
like mark cerny in there like who saved
sony a little bit this generation who is
going to save them for making a lot of
the inane no not even making innate
decisions but not recognizing the
important decisions that had to have
been made especially with like you know
unified accounts internet connectivity
like social networking across platforms
i feel like they've probably got storage
in mind at this stage and the flash cart
thing like yeah you can produce discs
easily but you can also damage them
really easily
so i it's kind of a toss-up i think i am
super excited for in general uh my
friend who knows like obviously like
nintendo sony and xbox who they are and
whatnot but doesn't necessarily know
like like keep up on the news he was
asking me like what the switch is and at
first i was gonna say it's kind of like
i was gonna say it's like the wii if you
could bring the tablet anywhere but with
like detachable controllers and whatnot
but it was like it's kind of like a 3ds
itself coupled with a home console but
you're playing the game on both
i don't know if that's like an accurate
description i mean the distinguish
to distinguish between your phone and
3ds comes down to features i think but
really it's just portable gaming console
gaming that are on parity for the most
part
done in a convenient way
that doesn't require jumping through a
lot of hoops
yeah that's the thing i want to get into
now because we did see a few games that
they showed during the presentation uh
one was like a new 3d mario game that
they didn't really they just kind of
showed it and didn't address it uh also
like one quick thing they showed skyrim
but then it came out afterwards that
skyrim is not confirmed for the console
oh is that even worse well that's
bethesda being we didn't announce this
yet right
even if like
they hit like we have every intention of
putting it on this it's part of that
that cycle that they put it into like we
have the time when we will announce
these things we have not officially
announced this game yet even though
you've seen it running on this console
don't
and there's also the possibility that
nintendo could have jumped the gun or
they could have talked with bethesda and
said like
this is something we'd like to put on
the system this is what it'll look like
and they didn't get permission yet just
put it on the reel force their hand i
love to imagine todd howard at home
drinking a glass of wine or something
seeing skyrim spit take all his tv
that's my game and then no one todd
what's the matter
the bastard stole my game no uh yeah
then like the 3d mario what is what was
that
i mean i'm sure like nintendo has had
some sort of statement about it like
we're just not announcing it nothing
like they haven't even said like no i
mean it's potential
what we see of that is a very small
slice so i've even seen conjecture that
it's just like an endless like a 3d
runner and it was possible because
you're literally just running on a
single track i don't think it will be i
think it will be a full
3d mario game yeah but i think that was
also more proof of concept and like an
idea yeah yeah it's hard to say it's a
surprise that there's going to be a
mario game on this nintendo console but
i guess it was the what the heat and the
excitement of the moment like that we
saw like what was that because justin
like played mario far more than i have
and he's like i don't recognize a level
from anything you know i thought maybe
just like 3d land or whatever 3d world
whatever the most recent one was 3d
world 3d world um but i guess i wanted
to talk about like what other kind of
ways they could like make cool games for
this console i mean like however
far-fetched you want to get but we know
we know what they're going to do in the
in the beginning there's going to be a
mario game there's going to be we know
zelda that's the only actually confirmed
title splatoon
splatoon is they showed that is that a
port
yeah but there was like well i mean
probably a port there were new hair
styles someone got all excited no way
nintendo switch your hair i think they
showed mario kart as well on there yeah
like but are these games that are just
going to get updates on the wii u or are
these full new titles it felt like what
we saw that these were slight
modifications on existing games so mario
kart 8 right split i feel like someone
pointed out in mario kart on the
in the preview video that you're able to
have two two once yeah yeah so that's
like graphically it looked very simple
first and second place you also like
both of you
blue shell yourself that'd be sad i just
blew myself
what were you saying
in a way those aren't even the things
that are interesting those are the what
we expect we know this is going to come
to every nintendo console there's going
to be a pokemon game it's like what
level are they going to take that to but
the thing that i think is interesting to
talk about would be third party titles
and even do does that matter it's been
so long since a nintendo console has had
a strong third party support and i have
a ps4 at home most of us have an xbox
one or a ps4 or a pc that plays all of
the the biggest games that we want to
play like skyrim do we need a
nintendo console to also fill that gap
no i mean we need the nintendo console
to get nintendo games and then
whatever it does otherwise that's kind
of like the icing on the cake and i know
that sounds really
like fanboyish like it's worth it just
for nintendo's stuff but like i mean by
and large that's kind of true if you
like what they do like investing a
couple hundred bucks to play their games
isn't that big of a leap um
so yeah like i don't think they're going
to be able to sell it to anyone but
nintendo fans like the same problem
they've always had apart from the wii if
this is as powerful as an xbox 100 ps so
the pure conjecture we don't know what
it's it'll probably be close to a ps3
you use xbox 360. it's not wii u is
pretty close to a ps3
i mean they're not terribly far off but
i mean this will be more powerful than
the wii u but i think it would come
pretty close to ps4 xbox one i think
they almost have to no i don't think
that's possible battery life battery
life would not allow that
because that's a thing that would make
it i i wouldn't say a replacement but at
least something that you might turn to
if you're if you're looking at what's
the next big game i'm going to get if
you're not someone who's invested in the
playstation 4 pro or the xbox scorpio
sure but like so for me it's a second
screen experience thing right if you
look at okay yeah i can play remote play
on my vita it's a shitty service it
doesn't work that well oh i could play
remote play on my laptop for my ps4 but
that's like a big cumbersome laptop
right to actually have this really
easily convertible thing you just pick
it up you plop the you can leave the
controllers attached if you want to but
it really does make just playing any
game so much easier when you're not
relying on your tv and so if they can
deliver like decent performance for
games that sure maybe they're out
already
or they're new games that aren't as
high-tech that's still offering
something totally different
than just purely playing a console game
on a tv like
the wii u couldn't handle what these
games are doing because the gamepad was
just a receiver this gamepad will have
the tech in there so you'll you'll be
getting really good experiences on a
small screen that's really convenient to
play when you're done with it you just
plop it on and charge it play on the tv
like that just sounds like such a great
scenario to me that i'm not i don't
think the power is going to be the thing
i think it's the convenience of
transforming how you play games and i am
right in assuming that if you are to
take it like on the go as like a more
3ds kind of type thing it's going to be
the same you're going to be robbed
people will steal it from you right but
it's also the same game you're playing
tv there's no scenario where i don't
know like in an ideal world you could be
playing a 3d mario on your tv like with
the home console then you go take it as
a 3ds and it becomes 2d
no no i think if anything you'd see the
resolution dip or the frame rate dip but
at the same time they could also dial
back some special effects maintain the
frame rate but again a smaller screen
you don't need as much high resolution
so
and i don't think that we're going to
see a huge power boost like there's been
some conjecture that when you put it
into the console at least from what
they've shown in the video when you put
it into that base stand that there could
be a graphical improvement of uh of like
having extra processing power in the
base and the way they showed it i don't
think that's possible because you're
basically hot-swapping graphics cards
they did in an interview they said that
no it will not provide more processing
power in the base but if you go back to
the battery life thing they could dial
back some of the processing like
literally
you know kind of like hold back the
processor when it's not docked and then
just let the processor work as it should
when it has more power and battery life
isn't a concern so technically yeah the
dock could provide an envelope for
better performance but i
i'm pretty sure they're on record saying
that no there's not like an extra thing
in the base station so what's the switch
going to do from a gameplay perspective
that the wii u
didn't
because the wii u was basically a
stand-alone call that was my second
console and i played it
purely for nintendo games and ultimately
it felt like it it didn't deliver like
what's going to be different about the
switch i don't know what obviously i
don't know what will be what i really
hope is that nintendo deliver and
something that most people aren't
talking about they really nail a good
operating system for this thing because
people are going to treat this device
like a tablet you couldn't do that with
the gamepad it was cumbersome it was big
it was low resolution it didn't have
great tech so this will essentially be a
nintendo tablet right
if they can
sorry i lost the specifics of your
question what can they do to
i mean what what is it that will make
this different than the we like
are there
no i don't think it's going to be the
software that makes a difference apart
from more third-party games that is
probably going to be the only difference
we see here i really think this is more
of a tech move
and sort of a twist
on concepts that they've dabbled in
before
and even
just taking mobile gaming and just
showing all these companies what they're
doing wrong like
why hasn't apple or you know any android
manufacturer come out with like a really
good software platform that works with
really good hardware that lets you just
focus on games without all the other
like bs that comes with working with ios
and android like nintendo will really be
able to be like this is the mobile
high-tech gaming platform
and it's also your console that was the
main appeal to me like watching the
trailer and seeing what they're trying
to do with it is like the 3ds has always
worked well for me for local connection
over wi-fi or whatnot um that was the
most appealing thing to me i'm not going
to stop playing basketball to play nba
2k16 like they did in the trailer but it
is cool like to see like four people
around playing it like the console games
for all intensive purposes maybe like
downgraded graphics like you said but
you know within close proximity as
opposed to like having to play over like
you know like almost a lan party with
just these smaller screens yeah and
that's the most appealing thing to me
for and i'm like thinking through my
head like what kind of games like it's
all the first party stuff it's mario
kart it's you know like the mario co-op
mario games and whatnot i don't better
be metroid that's better that's the one
i guess like everybody wants because the
new zelda we all played at e3 i think
that was like game spots you know like
unanimous kind of game of the year and
it was awesome and it seems like it's a
return to form in a lot of ways and i'm
curious how
they're going to use the switch to kind
of do something new with zelda because i
feel like zelda has always been
every zelda game that comes out like the
first one on each console is kind of a
proof of concept for the console skyward
sword finally nailed motion graphics um
was it twilight princess show that they
could sort of be used on the the wii
um i'm wondering what they might be
doing with zelda to show the switch off
there are some weird patents that
nintendo has handled recently like one
that has like a light projector on the
side of the tablet that literally shows
people interacting with things like with
light hitting their hand and then like
so i think the patent shows someone like
throwing a ball towards the screen and
then like their friend being able to
actually play it if that comes true and
that's a part of this
that's a lot of weird ass possibilities
but i think really nintendo is going to
focus on just i hope
making these just good standard games
that aren't relying on a gimmick right
that aren't forcing you to use the
gamepad because hey look what i can do
right like that was such a huge problem
for games like star fox like that was
the pinnacle of nintendo's hubris and
they they couldn't even admit it at the
time and i feel like this is a a very
firm
like statement like
okay we heard you guys yeah like
here is just a straightforward thing
that just gives uses tech that actually
makes it more convenient for you not to
show how clever we are sure as a company
yeah stop trying to prove yourself and
just get out of your own way um when you
said metroid i assume you mean like a 2d
or do you like i mean i love the price i
love prime no i just want a good metroid
game i just want to be back in that
world federation force shouldn't do it
for you well games that i don't want are
multi oh split screen multiplayer and
they showed that
with that ridiculous nba basketball demo
where he's like oh we're gonna go play
basketball now we're all gonna share
half a controller and play split screen
like that that seems horrible like well
i'm not gonna split my phone screen and
do multiplayer on that i'll play
bomberman that way maybe not nba but i
play some games like that yeah i can't i
can't kick bombs at my friend i can play
basketball five feet away with them not
very well but i could play basketball i
love video games but the real thing is
right next to you just go do that
or go home and play nba 2k16 i'm just
being a curmudgeon right now
but yeah that is the nintendo switch so
those are kind of like our impressions
on the tech and the actual what software
might come out of it let us know what
you think in the comments below
justin haywald resident nintendo geek
no i'm just kidding you hate when i call
you that i you you're critical of
nintendo i'm just joking i'm critical of
nothing i love everything anyway i'm
gonna get you out of here on time unlike
you arrived and that changed
a chair has seen a lot of action today
all right yeah we've got a new person on
for each segment here's rob hanlery
how are you
titanfall 2. i've been dying to talk
about this since our review went up uh
rob you and i played a lot of you were
at the review event with me down in
hollywood yeah man uh you and i both
seem really positive about this game i
gave it a 9 out of 10. i think it's an
awesome sequel i think it's a really fun
shooter i think respawn nailed it what
do you think i think
your score concurs man that's your
opinion yeah i think it's
it's easily one of the
best games for me as far as the year
goes like top game for sure if not the
top like battlefield 1 and titanfall 2
are like neck and neck as far as like
enjoyability and like doom even did some
work on me like i love that game too but
uh this
game is something else where
just to start off just the movement in
general like it's addicting like i
constantly want to move in this world
may it be single player or multiplayer
uh it's just so fun to play yeah we
talked about this last episode but if
you're a shooter fan this year is not
like doing you any harm there's
overwatch there's doom there's
battleborn if that was your cup of tea
there's gears of war four there's
battlefield three there's call of duty
coming out everyone's just doing some
interesting things yeah uh and then
titanfall 2 now uh i absolutely love
this game i think in terms of being a
sequel i uh you know like we talked to
respawn this summer and they told us
what their intent was but to me it
really does feel like it is the game
that they probably wanted to make back
if they had the numbers back in uh when
they formed respawn and when they
released a game in 2013 for the xbox one
um i think in terms of being a sequel it
seems like the changes are minor at
first right it's these six new titans
which are kind of uh more hero units in
themselves more there's more character
to them they're not these three variants
like light medium heavy uh they're not
like they have their own set loadouts
you can change them a little bit but for
all intense purposes they're almost like
superheroes there's you see ion right
here with like the laser attacks and
then you'll see uh scorch with the flame
attacks you'll see tone who's more
explosives and they all have these
little quirks that kind of the more you
play the more will come out and that
reminds me of hero shooters and mobas
right you're learning these people uh
you know i hate the phrase is overused
all the time but this game is really
easy to learn but it's difficult to
master and start like being really good
at it um obviously there's two layers
between the pilots and the titans for
those unfamiliar with the first game the
pilot's like it still is
the game to be in terms of movement i
know like black ops three has done it
advanced warfare had its own movement
system uh call of duty infinite warfare
is doing something similar overwatch had
some characters i could wall run and
vault and double jump but here like you
said it still just feels
unreal it feels really good and now that
i'm playing like battlefield which of
course is a slower game and i love that
game but anytime i play anything else
now i'm just kind of getting like antsy
i want to like ground slide do a double
jump to the wall and then vault over
something yeah
and in both the campaign and multiplayer
the mobility factor of chaining wall
runs and jumps and stuff like that is
really rewarding and i think in actually
like two different ways like uh
multiplayer
i guess both games
when you are chaining these wall runs
you're gaining speed
so when you consider a game mode like
capture the flag where you can then
combo it with stim which just gives you
a freaking
just a rush of energy and speed you just
can fly across a map dependent on on
your ability to to utilize that
traversal aspect and you can score flags
and if you're good at that then you are
just a valuable runner um and then you
know we were talking about a handful
about single player
uh
the game even says it like when you die
this is not a duck and cover shooter
like when you're playing on a higher
difficulty you are it says in a death
screen menu it says
when you are wall running you are
gaining momentum you're gaining speed
and that makes you a harder target to
hit for enemy ai so you are just looking
at every map in this game and single
player especially at each level and
you're just trying to find you know just
predictable routes just how do i get out
of this sticky situation you're giving
enemies uh grunts to have these crazy
shields the only way to basically kill
them is to get behind them so then
you're comboing your your cloak to
basically
get that wall run and get behind them so
they don't see you there and then you
get your your kill on that guy uh it's
just there's so much creativity in how
you play that
i'm literally playing this campaign
again uh like for the third time uh it's
just so fun to play yeah and people are
giving it [ __ ] just because it's like
four or five hours and uh it it is on
the short side uh you and i were talking
about you should definitely play if
you're pretty experienced with shooters
i played on hardened like the third up
third tier up and i still only died like
five six times maybe throughout the four
and a half five hour campaign
um the campaign doesn't feel tacked on
though i feel like they put a lot of
work into it despite its length um i
didn't like the writing at all you like
p you played the first few minutes and
that really that intro scene like a
pilot in his titan i was it was really
ham-fisted and i was like
soldier on the battlefield yeah
the dude with the cigar in his mouth and
just drunk like somewhere in the
appalachian
yeah like you guys have talked about
some stuff that sounds really
interesting like between titan and pilot
like the sort of relationship that
develops that sounds kind of interesting
to me i still haven't gotten that far
yet the bright spots in the plot and the
writing are definitely between your
titan bt7274 who has a personality he's
ascension thing but he also despite how
smart he is he doesn't understand human
phrases so jack cooper the main
character be like uh i missed or you
miss me or something or did you miss me
he's like i wasn't shooting at you
that'd be a violation of my protocol or
something how could i miss you and he's
like never mind those never mind can get
funny but i feel like the writing relies
too much on that and then um the
villains themselves are the most
outlandish just villains
after a while they lean into it but it's
still there were other parts where the
campaign was trying to be really serious
i was like what are you going for with
this narrative
but in terms of design speaking of those
villains they're like boss fights and
then the missions are constantly
changing up how it's using the pilot
movement the pilot combat how the titan
combat has figured into it you see bts
throwing you right here really good
platforming throughout the game this
section kind of becomes more of a puzzle
platformer almost mixed with a shooter
um and there's one mission that i wish
we could talk about um you were talking
about flanking guys and like kind of
manipulating your environment
i really wish we could talk about it
more people play it's like three
quarters away through the campaign but
it's this mechanic that comes out of
nowhere and you're like what is this
doing and then you start to slowly
understand it my point being i don't
want to spoil that the campaign is
paced really well you'll get into these
like mid-air ship battles where you're
jumping from ship to ship uh your titan
will factor into it um your titan itself
bt unlike the
titans from multiplayer you could switch
on the fly once you collect them all um
you can't go back and replay the
campaign with all the loadouts which
sucks you still get them at certain
intervals certain spots in each mission
but you just press right on the d-pad
and you switch to scores depending on
the situation there's a kind of a like a
reaction like a dynamism that you don't
have a multiplayer because you can't
walk into a firefight be like [ __ ]
northstar the sniper would be better for
the situation rather than
legion the minigun wielding one um that
became really fun especially during boss
fights like i think i killed
one boss using four different titans uh
which is loadout sorry same titan but
different loadouts and sometimes it
really requires it like especially on a
harder difficulty i found
uh
certain bosses you have to predict right
a scorch for instance a scorch boss
would like you know coat the area with
fire
maybe i should step back and use a north
star type and snipe him
and then you'll get a different you know
as and then you grow accustomed to that
tactic right but then the next level or
match you're faced with another titan
who's doing the exact opposite so you're
forced to like switch your loadouts and
yeah again like on the fly many of times
you're just throwing a situation like
you know north star is another good
example of someone who doesn't have like
any defense so then you're you're
switching around and you're throwing a
tone shield down in order to snipe
through like it's just you're going back
and forth in a very um like up-paced
manner that's keeping you like really
engaged
and thinking ahead yeah yeah despite the
fact that you can't switch loadouts on
the fly in multiplayer unless you're
like respawning or whatever uh there is
a certain visual vocabulary to this now
it's almost like i keep talking about
like mobas or hero shooters i
interviewed vincent pella back at e3
he's the ceo of respawn used to be like
called infinity ward and wanted he was
saying they actually looked at fighting
games in terms of how you want to fight
like
obviously it's gonna be very different
but like with overwatch you recognize
that that's a zarya coming around the
corner you should probably be ready for
her graviton surge or something you
learn the titans not just to know how to
attack with them but also how to counter
them and how to exploit their weaknesses
which is a huge deal in this game and
that's what i really love about these
titans if you see
you'll recognize scorch if you don't
recognize his body itself which is very
distinct from the others he's not skinny
he's this big huge dude with uh like a
like a kind of oil tank on his back
whatever it is
on his back he almost looks like a uh
bioshock big daddy totally that's
actually
gonna say the other day when i saw him
uh but then you have northstar who's
skinny but has this these like four
prongs jetpack coming off and you
immediately recognize that if it's
silhouettes yeah if it's a scorch and
like if you're ronin and you have a
sword you should probably get up close
to scorch before he can coat the area in
flames to kind of push you away if
you're a scorch and you see a north star
you should probably
try to get behind cover and lob your
artillery over these things instead but
that's what i really love about this
multiplayer it seems like a minor change
just switch up the classes but it
results in these like ripple effects
that kind of like create this really
kind of like cool gameplay loop between
not just like between pilot and titan
but also just the titans themselves and
speaking of the moba element i think
that's so strong in the game type last
titan standing
just you know five e5 people are so
cautious there you like and you get that
same element too of like ever you see
everyone's choice for titan you all
can't be ronin's you're gonna get
crushed some like someone can counter
that but you know as rounds progress you
can kind of move around but you want
that tone who can throw down basically a
shield for everyone to use in lanes
you want someone to basically sneak
around and flank like like a ronin like
you kind of like can work around that
and it gets really competitive uh
that mode and that's a mode that i never
really that was in the first game right
i believe it wasn't sending you yeah
yeah of course and i never really played
that you know attrition and you know
another one and even bounty hunt is
another look bounty hunt's great yeah uh
bounty hunt to paint a picture it's
you're each time you kill grunts so
there's not ai in every mode i know
people were worried about that people
who didn't like the ai if you're just
playing skirmish there's no grunts it's
just pilots and titans there's pilot
versus pilot mode now just like the
movement the more call of duty-ish
combat but bounty hunt's great because
and this is one of those modes that like
kind of like
makes you reconsider how to play the
game you gain money by killing grunts
and other pilots and titans but then you
can save it up uh if someone kills you
they get half your money into their like
wallet or whatever but then at a certain
point the match at the end of each wave
of grunts
three or four banks will open up and
everybody's rushing to deposit and you
have to hold x and your money will drain
so you're not automatically going to put
all your money into it so a you have to
get out your titan to do that you can't
you have to be a pilot so that's the
best part about the whole because there
will be other pilots who are
jerks like me who will camp out and
watch these banks and wait for pilots
just come in and deposit like 750 bucks
and get half of whatever that is for
killing them and deposit my own if you
didn't make any money that's your goal
now is to prevent people from doing that
yeah and also there's uh what's the
other one yeah like pilot versus pilot
feels great but i mean like watching
this footage to go back to what i love
about this game uh the first titanfall
people got burnt out and i know like
they were trying to figure out how they
could kind of uh give it more vitality
longevity uh in the long run and
you it's not always cranked up to 11
there are these calm moments where
you're like making a plan and trying to
figure out what to do next and the maps
are pretty wide open this time around
first one had some bigger maps but these
in general are you know facilitate both
pilot and uh titan combat but you keep
playing and the more i play the more i
learn like um
tone the the who's kind of like a call
of duty-ish titan you know he's got this
regular marksman explosive rifle and
shoulder-mounted missiles but you have
to instead of just like hovering your
reticle over someone to lock on you have
to actually attack them so i think it's
the base one is you have to hit them
three times with uh your gun but then
you find out that this sonar thing you
could shoot also automatically gets you
one tick toward locking on to shoot your
missiles and then ion rob neither you
nor i knew that
all of their like her attacks the titans
of xi um will feed into one central
power core so if you're just firing your
gun's alternate fire that's taking away
from what you could be using with your
shoulder mounted laser right um and
that's one mutual cooldown that you have
to manage and there are these weird
little wrinkles with each titan that
actually kind of make you play a certain
way and then obviously north star being
like the glass cannon if you hover it's
kind of like um pharah from overwatch
you can hover and shoot missiles
downward at titans or pilots alike uh
there is a certain amount of trepidation
when you're about to because you're like
i could get
really [ __ ] up if there's three north
stars on the other side of the map about
to shoot me um and then you have ronin
like these little like you know each
titan can add an extra dash to their uh
loadout yeah ronin starts with two so if
you add that third dash and then you
have the phase shift which is when ronin
goes into like another reality and then
appears like somewhere like 30 feet away
i came around the corner and last titan
standing and i saw a north star at the
other end i'm like [ __ ] i dodged to the
right i dashed to the left that like
dashed again and then i used phase warp
and i was right next that would have
been possible if i didn't change my
loadout like that right that's not
something i would consider until i
actually like played a lot of ronin and
that's what i think is also really nice
is because that you're getting those
hero shooter elements of recognizing a
an enemy and knowing how to handle it
however you'd still get that
customizable
aspect to meet your play style so for
ronin yes you have high mobility well
you know what i'm gonna go all out i'm
gonna add that other other dash and i'm
gonna focus on basically getting to
someone quick enough or north star you
know extremely weak
no defense i can add another tether to
slow people down but you know what i'm
just to go all out and just you know
make it a more powerful titan so yeah
that's really fun and experiment with
some of these and some of these are like
really like will come off as really big
game changers like give 20
more to your core ability right so if
you have a favorite core ability damn
you're getting that much quicker and uh
it's just more effective i don't know i
just i can't wait to
and that's where i i hope to see the
longevity of the game is like getting
these unlocks later on and then being
able to like master them down the road
um obviously there are other gimmicks
that are appealing like
skins and such like there's something
about
putting some sick ass teeth on
it's like a spitfire from world war ii
yeah it's war paint like some of them
are just like you know
teeth that go up past your ear like if i
was a north star hovering over you you
see that i i'd wet myself
and that's like it kind of speaks to how
attached you get these titans that you
actually care about aesthetic stuff like
like i don't know like overwatch is
another example all the unlocks and
overwatch are aesthetic yeah and that's
because i think you care about these
characters um but yeah and then i mean
like you just mentioned they have a
progression system now as opposed to
just the burn cards in the first game
and it's pretty steady from where you
and i played i think i played about
20
a few more than 20 hours total of
multiplayer between the review event and
this past week before it went live um
servers should go back up thursday you
know when it releases
way out east and we'll get to play more
i'm really excited too yeah and just to
tap on again they did a nice thing with
the burn cards i was never a huge fan of
those burn cards because you're just
given so many at such at such a high
rate that is anyone a fan of those i
don't know i mean i guess burn cards in
general no one i mean i'm not a big fan
of them but but the amount of cards
you're getting it was hard to manage
when you found yourself going through
them all
i feel like they did a nice thing of
basically taking you know the burn cards
and putting them into the pilot boost so
as you progress you know once you get to
level 50 you can get these really cool
ones like um
just i have to say uh tracer's
time warp back you know what i mean like
you're getting these abilities later on
that you want to get to and
what seems to be a nice ways away which
is which makes the game yeah i mean
hopefully
um
long term for people definitely it's
also cool like mixing and matching the
pilot loadouts with the titans like this
toilet like having cloak and also
there's that titan ability where you
eject when it's about to explode you'll
automatically cloak so people can't just
immediately pick the other one out of
the air like you did to me earlier on
this segment i was laughing because
while you were talking behind you i saw
the footage
uh you smoking with north star but
anyway yeah there's titanfall 2 the
review is up on site i gave it a 9 out
of 10 i really like this game uh
battlefield 1 is great call of duty i'm
curious about but i would encourage you
not to ignore titanfall 2 it releases
october 28th on ps4 xbox one and pc
well that's the show gentlemen that was
kind of a i don't know we've been going
past like three lately i don't care i
don't know if they can sign it to an
hour whatever yeah pete's back i'm back
we'll be back next week as well
halloween's coming up you guys have
plans you want a party what are you
being for halloween do you know rob
uh i'm i'm a huge halloween fan and i go
all out with my costumes one of the last
ones i was was a giant snail but that
was years ago right i was like you're
living in the past i think last year i
was i was a
luchador i was pretty fun
but i think i got one
coming up i don't want to spoil it but
it's going to require some uh late night
oh [ __ ]
and tailoring i've got a group one plan
with a few people here i think i'm going
out of town for the weekend but i'll be
here for friday i was weird considering
dressing up for the lobby but it
wouldn't have made sense like halloween
is what a week from yesterday
we're i'm getting excited about anyway
we're like halloween people you don't
seem like a costume person
what does that mean
you just told me this morning you're not
a costume person you said i don't seem
like one so i you don't see you're not a
costume person there you go i wish i was
i really freaking wish i was but i don't
know man i lack the energy i lack the
ambition oh i'm losing the energy as
well man i'm getting like closer and
closer to the deadline of like what the
hell am i going to be yeah yeah i don't
know forgive me for finding joy in
holidays still i guess i'm not jaded
you did rely on someone else to buy your
costume for oh [ __ ] all right whatever
trash talk is over that's our show
thanks so much for joining us for about
an hour and 15 minutes a little bit long
but whatever whatever we'll see you next
week at 2 p.m pacific on the lobby again
see ya
you